albançoire monsieur Marion alors comment
avez-vous reçu ces chiffres aujourd'hui
est-ce que
8,6,8% plutôt c'est plus élevé que ce à
quoi vous vous attendiez un peu plus je
préfère comme plusieurs économistes
passives d'exclure plusieurs choses dans
la nourriture puis l'énergie pour vous
dire que l'inflation est moins élevée
mais on peut pas faire ça je vais pas
mentir
il y a une certaine résilience qu'on
pouvait à constater le nom que le
changement mensuel a du zéro point 3
c'est une cadence moins élevée que du
6.8% sur une base de régime on a inspiré
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus faible
pour le mois d'octobre l'épicerie
11,4% sur un an c'est très élevé est-ce
que les prix vont finir par diminuer en
épicerie et je vais vous dire une chose
il y a une corrélation très forte entre
le prix de l'énergie et le prix de la
nourriture ça prend de l'énergie pour
faire la nourriture ce que l'on constate
depuis entre le mois d'octobre et le
mois de novembre j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour vous le prix d'énergie est en
baisse le prix du blé est en baisse ce
qui laisse présager un mois de novembre
qui sera peut-être un chiffre
d'inflation plus
réconfortant pour les ménages un mois de
décembre
qu'on a eu aujourd'hui on aura les
données du mois de novembre parce que
entre octobre et novembre on a déjà
constaté en fait allons-y extrapolant
jusqu'au mois de décembre moi ce que
j'essaie de vous prédire c'est depuis le
entre au mois d'octobre et maintenant on
a une baisse du prix d'énergie baisse du
prix du blé ce qui laisse présager que
les deux prochains mois seront plus donc
ça devrait éventuellement se refléter
dans le prix de des aliments absolument
puis moi je vais vous donner un chiffre
l'inflation 6.8% comme mouvementé moi je
pense qu'on va commencer l'année 2023
autour de 5% puis on va entrer le on va
entrer au printemps autour de 3% si on a
raison avec les tendances actuelles et
combien ça va prendre de temps à revenir
à
la écouter il faut se rendre à 3 % en
premier lieu moi je pense que 3 % peut
être atteignable dès ce printemps ce qui
serait si ça neuf mois plus rapide que
ce que les banques centrales prédisent
présentement ce qui serait bien
excellente nouvelle pour les taux
d'intérêt évidemment et à quoi vous
attendez-vous en termes de taux
directeur est-ce que la Banque du Canada
va prendre une pause comme certains
disent est-ce que ce sont vos prévisions
aussi moi je pense que oui puis il faut
bien il faut pas oublier que l'inflation
c'est l'indicateur le plus retardé sur
le cycle économique l'inflation qu'on
voit au mois d'octobre se reflète à
croissance de la première moitié d'année
qui était vigoureuse au Canada
croissance du PIB autour de 3 % la
prédiction pour le quatrième trimestre
c'est presque pas de croissance au
Canada donc ça va se refléter dans les
chiffres d'inflation de début d'année et
à votre question quand est-ce qu'on
revient près de la cible d'inflation moi
je pense que c'est en deuxième moitié
2023 ce qui pourrait ouvrir la porte
peut-être même à des baisses de taux de
la Banque du Canada mais encore faut-il
y aller avec une pause donc j'espère que
les prochains chiffres d'inflation
seront contribuer à à peser la Banque du
Canada qui en a déjà fait beaucoup au
niveau des hausses auto-et-up mais
j'imagine que des baisses de taux
d'intérêt ça sera plus en deuxième
moitié d'année parce qu'on doit se
rendre à 3 % d'inflation donc une
inflation va déterminer la cadence des
taux d'intérêt pour la Banque du Canada
comment évaluez-vous les risques de
récession
écouter malheureusement je me sens me
présenter ici avec beaucoup de
convictions d'un côté comme de l'autre
je dois dire c'est à peu près 55 ans
parce que le risque pour la Banque du
Canada et c'est la même chose pour la
Réserve fédérale
à vouloir continuer sans prendre de
pause présentement vous augmentez de
façon importante les risques de
récession c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense que même si certaines personnes
qui disent oh l'inflation t'as trop
élevé pour permettre de prendre une
pause non la création c'est un
indicateur retardée on a on a eu des
hausses auto intérêts qu'on ne voit pas
en une génération là c'est en prendre
une pause pour la banque Canada d'autant
que le marché de l'emploi risque de
ralentir début 2023 justement quel sera
l'impact d'une récession sur le marché
de l'emploi il y a quand même la pénurie
de main d'oeuvre certains disent qu'il y
aura pas autant d'augmentation du taux
de chômage
et rapidement pour les gens qui ont vu
leur placement boursiers chuter cette
année comment est-ce qu'on entrevoit
2023 cette année soit une protection au
niveau du marché boursier parce que le
marché boursier qui a le mieux performé
donc dans des plaies à plusieurs
personnes qui disent faut investir en
dehors du Canada je pense que c'est
peut-être ma petite ma thématique là est
encore en place pour 2023 bien que 2022
a été une année frustrante parce que les
actions étaient en baisse les
obligations en baisse
le prix des maisons donc j'espère pour
2023 avec une pause des banques
centrales qu'on ait une meilleure cuvée
donc un peu d'optimisme quand même pour
les gens à la maison avec une pause de
banque centrales je vous apporte de
l'optimisme je vous remercie beaucoup
Monsieur Marion d'avoir été avec nous
bonne soirée pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]